the present world is developing and
improving its technology all the
technology and the growth is coming from
i.t and software the main reason behind
it and software is coding and
programming these coding and programming
skills hold a key in developing all
those technologies hey everyone welcome
to yet another exciting video from
simply learn in this session we will be
discussing coding for beginners however
before we begin the session make sure
that you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to click that
bell icon so you can never miss an
update from simply learn let's look at
the agenda for today's topic first we
will begin with learning what is coding
then we shall discuss why one should
learn coding then we will walk through
which language we should learn first
after that we will discuss some basic
examples and quotes after that we will
learn and discuss the best websites to
learn coding followed by that we will go
through some tips to improve coding and
finally we will wind up the session by
discussing jobs to be expected on coding
so without further ado let's get started
with our first topic in this session
what is coding computers do not
understand the human language so we must
use some languages for communication
that require coding to communicate with
the computer coding is the best way of
passing and translating the instructions
for communication with a computer it is
used to program and design websites
applications and lot other technologies
coding tells the computer which action
should pass and instructs the computer
what to do and how to do it using some
programming languages
now let's have a look at why one should
learn coding the present world is
dealing with a large number of
applications the growth and demand for
software is increasing rapidly at
present most of the applications and
technologies are dependent on coding and
programming the applications and every
implementation is developed using coding
and are helpful in every sector and
provide solutions even for complex
problems learning coding also has a huge
demand and impact on career growth most
of the jobs at present are from software
and id and these skills help get a job
quite easily learning to code helps to
improve communication and collaboration
skills learning to code enhances
technical skills and give you a new way
to approach the work these are a few
reasons why one should learn coding now
let's have a look at which language to
start with there are many coding and
programming languages available in the
modern generation like cec plus python
and java every coding and programming
language has unique features when we are
ready to learn anything we have to know
the basics of the concepts when it comes
to programming the basic language and
the platform is c it covers some basic
concepts of the programming languages
and helps to have a good base for
getting more knowledge on coding once
you understand the concepts and basics
of c then it will be helpful for you to
learn other coding and programming
languages c programming covers all the
major topics like data types storage
classes operators functions memory
management file handling and many others
it is easy and possible to learn other
coding and programming languages once
you have good command and good skills in
the c language
now let's have a look at basic examples
and codes before being ready to
implement the code we must have to
specify the header files these header
files are used to perform specific tasks
in c programming we mostly use header
files like hash include stdio.h
and hash include con io.h once the
header files are mentioned in the code
we must take care of the main function
the main function serves as the starting
point of execution it executes the
program by calling other functions it is
like int main as shown in the video once
the header files are mentioned in the
code we must take care of the main
function the main function serves as the
starting point of execution it executes
the program by calling other functions
the main function contains the
instructions to tell the computer and
perform a specific task let's have a
look at a basic example of c program so
this particular program is a simplest
example designed in c programming
language you can see the red colored one
is hash include stdio.hs and header file
and followed by that we have a main
function with integer written type and
inside the function we have a simple
print statement which prints a message
welcome to simplylearn's youtube channel
and then we have return 0 which
indicates that the main function returns
null value and here you can see we have
the brackets which basically provide a
structure to the main code now let's
have a look at some of the platforms to
learn coding and the first one in the
list is skill up by simply learn skill a
platform is offered by simply learn
private solutions limited which was
founded in the year 2010 by mr krishna
kumar it offers free online courses for
those who are looking for better content
the main goal through skill up is to
build foundational skills for career
growth skill up also offers live
webinars with professionals to help in
the growth of technology the content
delivered by skillup is easy to
understand by everyone the courses from
scale up mainly focus on building strong
foundational skills there will be
certificates issued based on performance
after completing the course which holds
the key benefits of choosing skill up
and the next one in the list is
w3schools w3schools is a freemium
educational website for learning coding
delivered by worldwide web created in
the year 1998. this is one of the top
websites for learning coding mainly for
people who are looking for more content
and grip over the subject which involves
beginner to advanced this platform
provides a clear and neat explanation
for every topic there are plenty of
tasks and challenges for every topic
certification is provided by w3schools
is the key feature to choose the third
one in the list is hacker rank hacker
rank is a technical company that focuses
on competitive programming challenges
for both consumers and businesses it
helps in hiring for other companies and
helps in delivering good content it
includes java c plus plus php python sql
javascripts and spams multiple computer
science domains most of the companies
are choosing hacker rank to hire people
it provides challenge and practice
course to make it easy for people to get
more command over a subject it also
provides events for hiring with a lot of
vacancies and the fourth one in the list
is geeksforgeeks geeksforgeeks is a
computer science and non-profit
organization that contains well-written
well thought computer programs and
articles it also covers free tutorials
millions of articles live online and
classroom courses frequent coding
competitions webinars by industry
experts internship opportunities and job
opportunities geeks4geeks offers various
coding and development courses this
website also provides internships for
working professionals few exercises help
in learning coding without any
difficulty and the final one in the list
is code academy code academy is an
american online interactive platform
that offers free classes for coding on
12 different programming languages code
academy was founded in the year 2011 by
zak sims and ryan babinski located in
new york united states of america code
academy offers some free courses on some
top languages like java python web
development c-sharp swift and other
markup languages like css and html and
few other languages codeacademy is fully
loaded with real-time scenarios and
projects which is relatively easy to get
command over coding the content
delivered by codeacademy is pretty good
and impressive so these are a few
websites that offer free courses to
learn coding now let's walk through
learning some tips to learn coding
before we are ready to learn coding we
just have to start coding from the
basics it helps to gain knowledge and
makes it easy to concentrate so before
you are ready to learn coding start from
basics the main problem in learning is
consistency working daily helps gain and
boost your knowledge and helps us to
think logically and improve our skills
so we have to work every day to learn
coding one of the accessible sources of
learning coding and programming is
online resources there are plenty of
online resources like simply learn etc
these platforms are providing and
helping much in learning practice is the
best way to learn coding and programming
it takes a lot of time to represent but
helps more in gaining knowledge it helps
to get good command over coding easily
so these are a few tips to learn coding
now let's discuss on the few jobs and
their responsibilities by learning
coding and we have software developer
computer systems engineer business
intelligence analyst network
administrator computer programmer let's
discuss these job roles and their
responsibilities in brief so the first
we have software developer software
developer is responsible for researching
and designing implementing and managing
the software programs he is also
responsible for identifying and
modifying existing programs software
developers also possess different coding
skills and problem solving skills the
next one in the list is computer systems
engineer are responsible for developing
testing executing and evaluating
software and computers they are also
capable of improving and integrating
both software and hardware computer
system engineers should process project
management and time management skills
and the next one in the list is business
intelligence analyst business
intelligence analyst enhances the
approach and decision making of a
company by using the data and pass to
present they use data and work with the
data to improve the business of a
company or organization to become a
business intelligence analyst you must
be an expert in data analysis and
programming languages like python and
c-sharp the next one in the list is
network administrator network
administrator is responsible for keeping
the company network and companies data
secure they should be experts in
computer knowledge and possess strong
problem-solving skills network
administrators are also creative and can
describe the technical knowledge into
easily understandable terms for the
users and the final one in the list is
computer programmer computer programmers
are responsible for designing and
creating software programs integrating
systems and software they also train
end-to-end users analyzing algorithms
modifying data source and writing system
instructions debugging and maintaining
operating systems computer programmers
should possess strong programming and
problem solving skills and this was all
for today's session i hope you guys have
found it informative and interesting if
you have any queries regarding the
topics covered in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment sections below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here